[Music]
celebrating your win
is a satisfying experience but some
moments deserve
more than just the usual they deserve a
pop off
it's a staple of esports nothing both
feeds and
builds the height more than an
incredible pop
off just make sure you've actually won
it though before you do it so smart he
couldn't burst because of the super
but will she thinks
oh my god
but before we get into that just make
sure you are subscribed to the channel
if you haven't done so already that way
you'll never miss any great videos just
like this one
and with that let's get into the top 10
pop-offs
in esports history
kicking off our list is a pop-off from
the allegedly
oldest man in the game i'm holding [ __ ]
with the worst gun in the game at the
six invitational 2020
space station gaming faced off against
tsm in the events group stage
in a 1v3 situation canadian
had to find some way out as pulse
wielding what is legitimately not
a great weapon canadian down below
isolated he'll walk right into geo and
he wins the fight
but he will have to find the diffuser he
doesn't have the nitro cell available he
will miss
time it they'll be able to get out of
there very effectively
his retake from canadian will be tough
bullo's on only a tiny bit of hp
down goes merc bullo's one shot away
we'll create it oh my
god no way he pulls that off and the
defuser is his
afterwards canadian had some harsh words
for tsm
as well as his former teammate geo
oh my god why am i
so much better than you god
damn he's not [ __ ] humping you you
[ __ ] little [ __ ]
still get your [ __ ] hang i'm holding
[ __ ]
with the worst gun in the game you're
playing twitch geo
you're playing twitch listen canadian is
old as [ __ ] but wait you're saying he's
only 24 and geo is actually
older than him okay weird flex then but
still pretty hype
taking the number nine spot is a series
of pop-offs from the mad lions
it just never stops with the mad lions
yeah i didn't pay for this mad lions
have quickly become
one of the most exciting teams on the
rift most recently winning the 2021
lec spring playoffs but the organization
has a long history of hyping up the fans
off the rift as well
in the webcam only era they came up with
some
imaginative victory celebrations here
with the mad lions a little bit of a
different style
they took a bit longer to come online
but once it got down
this looked incredible i love the way
they're able to play around
he's putting something on his he's got a
guitar the man has a guitar
they've got an amp
[Music]
it's hard to imagine any league of
legends team carrying musical equipment
on stage so in a way maybe this is a
limited edition pop-off we could only
get in the online era
our number eight entry is the rare
wholesome pop-off
see at summer jam 7 tekker player pepper
beef 2 spicy
found himself facing off against north
america's champion
lil margin in pools the best of three
set went to
literally the final round and featured
plenty of hype moments
but at the end pepper beef beat the
people's champ
and he popped off with abandon in front
of a stunned
hostile crowd before sheepishly shaking
hands
oh my god oh and that will be that
never be too spicy knocks little margin
to loses
but then after margin moved to exit the
stage
it's like pepper beef realized he
actually needed to continue the pop
off so he just did his best impression
of the leo win pose
this is an extremely underrated pop-off
that offers a true
roller coaster of emotion and lil margin
was also a good
sport about it just an absolute classic
coming in at number seven is the pop-off
that gave any fans
everywhere hope cloud niner in the grand
finals
of esl one cologne 2017
and there we go they've taken off their
clothes at esl one cologne 2017
cloud9 made a deep run to semis we're a
round away from victory against navi and
nothing
came in clutch at the right time and
it's happening
nothing he does and he just stands up
ice cold
but for it to happen that way for
guardians then
after showing a dejected navi and their
fans
the camera returned to nothing who had
removed his shirt
and he didn't even put it back on for
the handshake line
i think if anything it might have been
like oh i don't want to touch you you
get your shirt off like kind of funny
but those guys definitely like hate
losing obviously
that the knob you guys just pure anime
protagonist energy from this pop-up
and number six pop-off is the direct
result of a truly impossible
play with nothing but a p250 chad i'm in
disbelief
clutches are difficult against the
world's best they're even harder when
you're t
side 1b4 the bomb is covered and you
have a p250
but sometimes miracles happen and what
did he do after that that's nuts
so he actually shoots the author in the
back of the head without anyone looking
that's the op and kills the guy ct
oh yeah ah yeah oh my god he's knifed
him and he's gotten away with the oil
punch time to get nervous
there's no way there's no way katie you
can't win pro league like this
you can't win pro league like this no
way exiles left 40 seconds and the bombs
on a
take your time son you're about to make
the play of your career
though he just has to hit this shot and
he's done it for heroic
the leader calling well above his years
clearing corners
you're an animal heroic have done it and
i just can't believe it 40
of their team only together since
february
and with nothing but a p250 chad i'm in
disbelief
there's no roar of the crowd here this
pop-off is
pure exhilaration from a team that
fought through the online era of cs
and were awarded for their hard work
with one of the best clutches
in counter-strike history
at our halfway point is a pop-off from a
man known for his celebrations
hungrybox yes oh my
oh my come come one calm yourself down
juan
but sometimes calming yourself down just
isn't an option
as the hype takes over and the only way
you can be stopped is
actual physical injury at smash and
splash 3 hungrybox faced
armada in winners finals and after an
extended bout
he won and pops off so hard he literally
had to see a doctor
holy cat wait holy cow that was winter
smiles
oh my god he's gonna break the tv to be
honest
i understand why right now yeah i mean
he's like he was holding it okay dude
after the event hungrybox confirmed that
he went to a doctor
and while there was no broken bones he
did have to wear a walking boot
the best part hungrybox still took the
entire tournament
even with the injury and then he
delivered an impassioned speech
what a beast we came here from the
gutter ourselves we can say whatever the
damn hell we want
we have no help we ain't had no we had
no help from
any person we came here to ourselves and
look at us we're still having
1500 people at a damn water park in
wisconsin who are we
come on now at number four entry is a
pop-off
so spicy that any young children
watching this might need to skip to the
next entry
and you're gonna want to wash the taste
of my dick out of your mouth
the first of ten is an important part of
the fighting game community
and since they are sometimes used to
settle a score a pop-off is
always a possibility and if one happens
it's likely to be
personal when biscan faced off against
the controversial
low tier god at wednesday night fights
in 2014
things were pretty tense and thankfully
the tension gave us one of the most
iconic pop
offs in history
why would we shake hands we do not shake
hands in crunch matches
wow wow he has done it
[Applause]
all right look
i got one more thing to say i got one
more thing to say
so there's going to come a point when
you forget about what happened
and you're going to want to come back at
me and you're going to want to wash the
taste of my dick out of your mouth
coming in at number three is a desk
destroying pop-off from stewie2k
it's team liquid and that's what it
means to them
what's the next best thing to winning a
valve major in counter-strike
well a million dollar bonus for winning
the intel grand slam sounds
pretty good to me esl one cologne 2019
was one of the most
memorable moments in nacs history as
liquid did the
impossible winning their fourth esl or
dreamhack event
in a 10 event window to win a cool
million
bucks it was na's greatest triumph since
winning the boston major and stewie
couldn't help but get a little bit
excited
two versus two and liquid have the
advances they're trying to bring it down
to the two versus one
if it's rpk this drop they could be in
serious trouble that should do it
there we go it's team liquid and that's
what it means to them
they've taken it at the fourth map the
favorites coming into the tournament
have just unlocked the intel grand slam
at esl one cologne underneath
our runner-up spot goes to the murder
face himself
takedow taquito's akuma has always
been scary but the japanese fighting
game phenom took his psychological
warfare to the next level in 2010 at
socal regionals
a little explanation here after akuma
performs the iconic
raging demon super he turns away from
the camera and the kanji 10
appears on his back which represents
among other things
immortality it's a street fighter staple
anyway at scr 2010 taquito beat klekey d
but he wanted to rub it in just a little
so
instead of shaking hands taquito walked
between the projector
and screen in the venue and mimicked
akuma's raging demon
victory poses
[Applause]
it's a legendary epic pop-off made all
the cooler because of taquito's
signature character choice
but there's one pop-off that's just a
little bit
better that's right and number one pop
off is
k brad giving wolf crone a little bit of
a lecture about himself
oh oh tell him tell him about himself
an incredible pop off has so many pieces
you've got the history between the
players the showmanship and the crowd's
reaction all
factored in this pop-off has it all
k brad and wolfcrone had lots of prior
history
and a recent loss meant k-brand was out
for revenge
of final round 20. so after securing an
easy dub
k brad made himself comfortable and
offered his rival some free advice
oh this is frank oh let me see this oh
[Applause]
everything about this pop-off is perfect
it has a history of disrespect
the attitude and several high-profile
members of the fgc
just giving us their raw reactions well
there we go guys that was a pretty tough
list to make there are so many
good pop-ups did we leave something out
that we really should have put on there
let us know in the comments section as
always thanks for watching and i'll see
you all
in the next one he's gonna have to deuce
i can't
nope no more oh my god genius
so smart he couldn't burst because of
the super
but will she get dicks it's over oh my
god